on this saturday night rogers says it's
responsible
the ceo's message to customers i
apologize we all here at rogers
apologize for the outage for the
nationwide network failure and why it
could happen again
the federal apology more than a century
in the making they were told that it was
a white man's war trudeau's message to
descendants of canada's only black
military battalion plus sri lankan
stormed the presidential palace
[Applause]
as the heads of government vow to step
down amid the country's worst economic
crisis in seven decades
and suiting up the stars once you meet
one they are taught
you know the master taylor in bc
bringing hollywood to his home
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight
nithu garcia good evening and thanks for
joining us rogers communications says
it's restored mobile and internet
service for the vast majority of its
customers a network-wide outage caused
chaos across canada yesterday with
service still spotty for many people on
the rogers network today the company's
ceo has apologized for the disruption
saying rogers will do better but experts
say without more competition history is
bound to repeat itself brittany rosen
tells us what went wrong and what's
being done about it in our top story
tonight
i apologize we all here at rogers
apologize for the outage rogers is
saying sorry following a nationwide
outage that left millions of customers
without internet access cell phone and
cable services for most of friday
contrary to what many thought was a
cyber attack one of the country's
largest telecom networks admits it's
responsible for the widespread service
disruptions we've narrowed the cause to
a network system failure we had a
maintenance upgrade in our core network
and that caused our routers to
malfunction the malfunction affected
pretty much everything canadians use on
a daily basis emergency services travel
and they were really really hooped
and not able to in this busy season
coming out of covid to make critical
sales
interact says services are back after
debit and mobile banking transactions
came to a halt rogers admits it has not
fully restored services to everyone
across the country as of saturday it
plans to credit customers for two days
worth of service for some people that'll
be enough but for other people who are
inconvenienced is that 15 or 20 credit
really gonna cut it
this is the second time in the last two
years rogers has had a nationwide outage
and the company's president and ceo
could not say for certain it will not
happen again i'm committed to make sure
that we are doing everything to ensure
the resiliency of our network without a
definitive plan b the ordeal has called
into question the competition or lack
thereof in canada with shaw bell and
rogers dominating the telecommunications
playing field competition is a good
thing and it works for everyone in such
an impactful way and i can only think
that something like this
elevates the conversation
around
internet service providers given the
major disruption there are now calls for
a public inquiry into the outage and for
the crtc to investigate brittany rosen
global news toronto
a historical moment today in nova scotia
as prime minister justin trudeau
apologized to the loved ones of canada's
only world war one black military unit
members of the number two construction
battalion had faced extreme racism and
prejudice while serving their country
alexa mclean was at the ceremony and has
more on the event and what the pm had to
say
the streets and stands of churro nova
scotia were filled with hundreds of
people who came out to be part of a
moment in canadian history that prime
minister justin trudeau acknowledged was
decades overdue i am here today
to offer the government of canada's
official apology for the appalling way
these patriots were treated
the surviving sons and daughters of men
who served in the number two
construction battalion were greeted with
a standing ovation in attendance for the
first federal government apology to
black canadians for overt anti-black
racism shown during the first world war
what do you think your dad elmer would
think today if he were here he'd been
right there talking and telling them
about you know
the war and all those and that when
world war one broke out in 1914 black
volunteers flocked to sign up at
military recruitment offices but were
denied the right to serve their country
in repeated acts of discrimination and
racism
almost every
single black volunteer
was turned away that led to an onslaught
of pressure from black community members
lobbying the government to overturn a
racist policy while they weren't allowed
to fight on the front lines they did
form a labor battalion that played a
critical role in building and
maintaining military infrastructure
overseas this is my father percy
richards he's the member of the society
well the main thing that struck me the
day almost brought me to the earth was
the apology
and knowing that they did do something
right in this
in the first war a part of canada's
history that's no longer in the shadows
for the blatant anti-black hate and
systemic racism that denied these men
dignity in life and in death
we are sorry
alexa mclean global news churro nova
scotia
protests in sri lanka have pushed the
country's president and prime minister
to announce their resignations the
island nation is in the middle of its
worst economic crisis since independence
in 1948. in recent days the government
ordered schools and businesses closed in
an effort to keep people out of the
streets as mike armstrong explains it
didn't work
the pressure in sri lanka has been
building for months saturday it boiled
over
protesters and police facing off with
protesters pushing harder
ignoring tear gas and warning shots the
crowd was able to force its way past
police into the home of the president
thousands entered the building after it
was abandoned by security
some even went for a swim
this man says the luxuries in the home
are a waste of national resources and
show the government isn't working for
the country
now in advance of saturday's protest the
president left his home friday the
pressure on both he and the prime
minister to resign has been growing
daily
we must chase them out this protester
says they must go it's time to think of
the country
the pressure appears to have gotten to
both men
action i can't get a country's
parliamentary speaker says the president
has agreed to step down next week and
the prime minister's office saturday
issued a statement saying he's willing
to step down to make way for an
all-party government to take over today
the people
show the nation and the international
community
the power of the
people
sri lankans are suffering there are
shortages of food fuel and medicine and
prices are skyrocketing and bring down
the inflation the head of the central
bank said this week inflation was up
more than 55 percent since last year and
predicted it could hit 70 percent
there's also no relief coming the
president said this week inflation could
be around until the end of next year
critics blame corruption and
mismanagement compounded by the pandemic
the situation in the country one critic
says isn't a cautionary tale it's a
horror story
it's also still being written
overnight the prime minister's residence
was set on fire
mike armstrong global news
the body of former japanese prime
minister shinzo abe arrived in tokyo
today a day after he was assassinated by
a lone gunman while on a campaign stop
the motorcade brought abe's body to his
home where a vigil will be held on
monday a private funeral is scheduled
for tuesday police are still trying to
determine the suspect's motive for
shooting abe but told japanese media
today he believed abe was connected to a
religious group he blamed for his
mother's financial ruin he allegedly
spent months planning the attack and
previously attended other abbe campaign
events including one the day before the
shooting
several communities in northern canada
are under evacuation alerts this weekend
as hundreds of wildfires continue to
ravage large parts of the region in
yukon and northwest territories more
than 250 fires are currently burning
with fears that number could grow as dry
conditions and scorching heat are
expected to continue into next week
environment canada has issued heat and
air quality warnings for parts of the
region uconn has also issued a
territory-wide travel advisory as some
fires come dangerously close to key
highways dozens of b.c firefighters are
helping to battle the blazes with more
said to be on the way
in the u.s hundreds of people have been
evacuated near california's famed
yosemite national park as the so-called
washburn wildfire continues to grow it
has scorched more than 280 hectares
since barking on thursday and is now
threatening some of the largest trees on
earth as jennifer johnson explains the
fire is being seen as another result of
the mega drought that continues to bear
down on the region
hundreds of firefighters are desperately
trying to stop the spread of the
washburn wildfire in yosemite national
park
but mother nature's high winds continue
to fuel the flames as the fire rapidly
spreads the red cross has set up a
shelter for hundreds forced to evacuate
if anyone needs a place to stay food to
eat water information they can come to
our shelter
firefighters are desperately trying to
save mariposa grove home to some of the
oldest trees on the planet this is one
of the most visited spots in yosemite
with 500 giant sequoias standing tall
it's some of the oldest trees that there
are there's trees that are 2 000 years
old they're
massive giants when you stand next to
them the washburn fire is one of several
destroying thousands of hectares in
california residents have been forced to
leave their homes because of the
electrifier near sacramento and the
butterfield fire close to the nevada
border for many evacuations are becoming
all too commonplace having lived in two
locations before prior to this that had
mandatory evacuations
it's
pretty disconcerting we were just
sitting out smoking our meat on the
barbecue
and i saw the smoke coming overhead so
we hooked up the trailer grabbed the
goods and
out we went california and other parts
of america's west have been suffering
through a 22-year mega drought more than
two decades of below average
precipitation
experts blame human-created climate
change for the severe conditions
wildfires have destroyed up to a fifth
of yosemite's 75 000 giant sequoias in
just two years everybody's been training
and preparing for this and that's what
everyone is here to do fight that fire
this mega drought also has rivers in
texas drying up great salt lake in utah
almost bone dry that is kicking up dust
storms affecting the health of millions
in the state
and california's wildfire season is now
becoming an almost year-round crisis
jennifer johnson global news washington
from travel tie-ups to claims in court
my wife and i decided well let's take on
air canada coming up this couple's
successful suit and what it could mean
for your next trip
plus australia comes to terms with the
climate reality of consecutive disasters
the busy summer holiday season is
bringing endless horror stories from
people traveling by air passengers are
looking for ways to stand up for
themselves and receive justice for the
way they're being treated as ross lord
reports some canadians are taking their
fight with the big airlines to small
claims court
when air canada disrupted their round
trip to florida rob and adrian mcnabb
did something unusual they sued the
airline in small claims court my wife
and i decided well let's take on air
canada
and as as the process turned out
i was able to prove that
yes
they were in the wrong and they had to
pay
they won a three thousand dollar
judgment a victory that could help the
escalating number of other canadians who
feel they've been mistreated there's the
ottawa man who flew air canada to the
caribbean for his upcoming wedding
obviously packed bought everything in
canada packed it all up
my suit my shoes my tie my
all the accessories and everything
cufflinks the whole works everything is
in my luggage
and
luggage never arrived this bc man who
says westjet changed his flight
itinerary then told him he's on the hook
for rearranging it i did exactly what
they said and in the end of it they
charged me 1200 more
and then they refused to give me back
the difference
and they won't even talk to me anymore
and the air canada customer who's
changed flight schedule was blamed on
poor weather i find it odd very odd that
they would know two weeks in advance
that
bad weather would cause a 15-minute
delay an airline that's funded in part
by tax dollars from those very same
customers it is an atrocity what they
are getting away with how can they get
away with it the trudeau government's
air passenger bill of rights is supposed
to protect passengers forcing airlines
to rebook or compensate for disruptions
but advocates say those protections are
being ignored often passengers complain
that their flight was canceled but they
cannot even reach the airline in
statements to global news both air
canada and westjet insist they are
meeting their obligations the canadian
transportation agency says it's issued
almost one hundred thousand dollars in
penalties against the airlines for
violating the passenger bill of rights
but advocates say considering the
widespread chaos penalties should be
much higher the airlines just aren't
thinking ahead
they took our money to begin with they
booked our our times and every single
flight we've booked in the last three
years has been changed at some point in
time the mcnabbs have launched a second
lawsuit in small claims court this one
against westjet a last resort they'd
rather not turn to every time their
plans for a relaxing retirement trip are
upended
ross lord global news
ahead changing the conversation around
climate change in australia gripped by
dangerous floods
you're watching global national
the areas around sydney australia are
finally seeing some relief from flooding
after nearly a week of downpours about
47 thousand people are still out of
their homes down from about 60 000 on
thursday after yet another devastating
flood in the region this year it comes
at a time when the climate change debate
is starting to shift in australia
following years of skepticism about the
science and solutions redmond shannon
has more
the scale of the flooding in and around
sydney has been enormous but it's the
pattern of repeated inundation that has
exhausted many residents like kevin
it's all either
i'm gonna move
some have seen their communities flooded
two three or even four times this year
alone absolutely devastated
it's really hard
scientists say the effects of the la
nina weather phenomenon and climate
change have combined to cause this
recurring nightmare but some affected
aussies like gay peters reject the
notion that man-made climate change is a
factor
i think it's garbage
[Laughter]
sorry it happens all the time it's a
flow ebb and flow
yeah i don't believe it anything to do
with climate change whatsoever
her opinion is not that unusual in
australia a country where you'll often
hear something like this on major media
outlets you know if the global warming
scare mongers and carpet baggers were
right none of this we're seeing there
would actually be happening we wouldn't
for a start be having one of our coldest
that was starts to a winter climate
activists say the media influence of
aussie born fox news founder rupert
murdoch has delayed widespread
acceptance of climate science
but attitudes began to shift two years
ago when bushfires burnt a quarter of a
million square kilometers of forest
because of the
ongoing flooding on the east coast and
because of the relentless fire seasons
that we're having everyone is realizing
that climate change is here and now
and i think that that has really kind of
passed through the psyche of the
community
that was reflected too in may's
elections
for australia to be a renewable energy
supervisor
new prime minister anthony albanese's
emission reduction targets go further
than his predecessor scott morrison but
reaching them will involve unpopular
decisions just like in canada the fossil
fuel industry in australia generates
revenue and jobs redmond shannon global
news london
coming up made in canada style on the
big screen
neighbors came rushing in
they said was that donald sutherland in
here says yeah i was the talented bc
tailor suiting up hollywood stars from
his home
[Music]
you may not recognize pat coco but
you've likely seen his work on the big
screen for nearly seven decades he's
been tailoring suits in burnaby british
columbia and for nearly half that time
outfitting big stars as jay durant
reports living in hollywood north means
he's become the go-to guy for many tv
and film productions
we're making a tuxedo here chances are
you've seen pat coco's craftsmanship on
the big screen burnaby's tailor to the
stars has been designing custom suits
for film and tv for almost 30 years
that's the leslie nielsen yeah there's
ben affleck this real yoda that's nick
nolte and of course it's late robert
williams and he comes out
without his shirt and ransom says holy
smokes would you get all that hair i was
out of my head
it all started when a movie costume
designer saw one of his suits in a local
store worried about the quality of his
work got around pretty fast so once you
meet one they all talk
you know coco's promising start as a
young tailor hit a small speed bump in
the 1980s when he briefly found himself
unemployed i wasn't going to lay down
and die
i was going to rebuild so he kept
designing for customers in his mother's
basement before moving to the double
garage in 1990 he relocated seville
taylors to its current location in
burnaby which means some star sightings
in the neighborhood and down there of
course is donald sutherland oh he was
right in the shop here right in the shop
right there after they left the
neighbors came rushing in
they said was that donald sutherland in
here he says yeah i was out of all of
his unique creations over the years one
stands out for coco look at that this
suit sean being warren snow piercer is
his masterpiece that's one of your
finest creations it is i call it mona
lisa
with hollywood north ramping up again
the phone is bringing off the hook which
has the tailor to the stars working some
very long days as long as my health is
good then god willing and
what else am i going to do it keeps me
going jay durant global news you know
and he looks sharp doing it and that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm nithu garcia tonight's your canada
is this month's drone light show in
selkirk manitoba we love seeing your
canada please keep emailing your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com
i'll be back here tomorrow until then
good night
[Music]
you